the discovery of a second batch of
classified documents this time inside
the garage of President Joe Biden's
private residence has made it difficult
for Biden to quell this latest political
controversy people know I take
classified documents and classified
materials seriously White House lawyers
revealed the documents were found
recently and relate to Biden's time as
vice president under President Barack
Obama
the White House lawyers insist they
immediately turned the documents over to
the National Archives still the
Department of Justice is appointing U.S
attorney Robert Herr a special counsel
to investigate whether Biden broke the
law
I will ensure that Mr Herr receives all
the resources he needs to conduct his
work the White House insists it's
cooperating and is denying any
impropriety it's in the statement of uh
from his lawyer Richard Sauber and at
the end he said we are confident that
they are a thorough review will show
that these documents were inadvertently
misplaced still it's an Administration
under increased scrutiny earlier this
week while Biden was at a summit in
Mexico the White House admitted lawyers
found similar secret papers at a
Washington DC Think Tank called the Penn
Biden Center the President says he
doesn't know what's in those documents
but the discovery has prompted charges
of hypocrisy
in January 2022 classified documents
were found at the Florida residents of
former president Donald Trump a justice
department special counsel is also
looking into that case Biden has called
Trump totally irresponsible for
mishandling the classified materials
another faux pas by the Biden
Administration but treating law
differently based upon your political
beliefs treats one president Trump one
way but treats President Biden a whole
different way President Biden's
Republican critics are are also
questioning why it took so long for the
Biden Administration to reveal the
existence of the documents the first
batch was discovered on November 2nd
just days before the Congressional
midterm election but only became known
to the public this week
Kimberly helken Al Jazeera the White
House